[Musik]
hallo tina hallo lisa wie geht's gut
danke und dir auch gut bist du zu hause
ja warum fragst du ich kaufe gerade eine
neue wohnung ist doch in der nähe vom
supermarkt ja ich möchte dich besuchen
hast du zeit ja gute idee den circa 20
minuten super ich bereite etwas zu essen
vor
bis gleich tschüss
20 minuten später
komm herein tina das ist meine neue
wohnung war so schön
stell deine einkäufe doch auf den tisch
das wohnzimmer ist groß und hell es gibt
zwei große fenster das sofa ist bequem
der fernseher ist modern
der tisch und die pflanze sind aus japan
die lampe auch oder ja und die kissen
hier auch komm mit ich zeige dir jetzt
die küche
das ist meine küche sie ist klein aber
praktisch es gibt ein waschbecken es
gibt einen tisch und zwei stühle
es gibt einen herz mit backofen es gibt
einen kühlschrank die küche gefällt mir
essen wir danach sushi ja aber komm ich
zeige dir jetzt noch das schlafzimmer
und das bad
das ist mein schlafzimmer es gibt ein
bett es gibt eine lampe ich habe eine
kommode aber ich habe noch keinen
kleiderschrank das bild ist schön
es zeigt meine heimatstadt in japan
hier habe ich noch einen teppich komm
mit wir gehen ins badezimmer
das ist mein bart es gibt zwei spiegel
ein lavabo eine toilette und eine dusche
ich habe zugenommen
nein nein die waage ist kaputt sie
funktioniert nicht richtig
ich bin erleichtert